this shot is from Atlanta home of Tyler
Perry's new at stork and massive new
movie studio complex we went behind the
scenes at the site that features a dozen
sound stages named after black icons in
Hollywood Tyler Perry's a creative force
behind 22 movies 20 plays 8 TV shows
he's very busy the 50 year old writer
director and actor told us what inspires
him to think big the star-studded grand
opening of his new film studio is quite
literally a dream come true
for Tyler Perry I'm gonna tell you
something there was a moment that
happened in 2005 at the legends ball I
promise you and I wish people were
Oprah's legends or is legends ball yeah
she invited me there my movie had just
come out during that black woman had
just come out first movie not a lot of
people knew me in the room and I'm
sitting there wondering what am i doing
in this room and Yolanda Adams sitting
next to me I think I said it out loud
because she goes you belong in the room
leaving there seeing it touching it
tasting it feeling it the excitement of
what it meant to see a woman a black
woman be able to do that spoke to me in
so many ways and I'm on video saying
listen in my car da glass is my zutsuu
thinking I'm looking great I said I'm
just absolutely floored and and my thing
leaving here I'm gonna dream bigger and
dream more and it opened me up to
believing anything is possible in many
ways it seems to me like you're just
getting started yeah does it feel like
that to you yeah because at 28 I went
into this show because I started touring
during 307 shows a year somewhere around
44 or 45 I came out of it and I go wait
a minute where did all those years ago
so now I feel like I'm still 35 so I
feel like I'm just getting started I
really there's nothing about me that
feels like 50 whatever that's supposed
to mean
everything I've done for the last five
[Music]
the land that is now Tyler Perry studios
sits on three hundred and thirty acres
with 12 sound stages there is even a
replica of the White House where he
films his new show The Oval it looks
just like it does on TV Tyler but before
Perry brought Hollywood to Atlanta this
was once Fort McPherson military base a
Confederate stronghold the property that
slaves built that was at once a
Confederate Army base think about the
poetic justice in that the Confederate
Army is fighting to keep Negroes
enslaved enslaved in America fighting
strategy planning on this very ground
and now this very ground is owned by me
it's an extraordinary accomplishment for
Perry whose journey includes overcoming
abused during his childhood at one point
losing everything including his home but
now his ride to work is a reminder of
how far he has come what did that mean
to you to see that on the highway and
it's a bonafide highway sign what that
means yeah first time I saw it it was
next to Sylvan Road which I remember
when I moved to Atlanta I moved off a
silver old my cousin and got put out a
house had no money that kind of thing so
I'm looking at so enrollment and then to
see my name next to that moment I just
it it took me tickle my breath away
people know your story you were homeless
you literally slept in your car you're
65 what kind of car was it Geo Metro
pretty tough yeah that's about this
that's right convertible but what is it
that you think that this happened to you
that you do really well that you're
really proud of I work very very hard
I this this entire journey of telling
stories was born out of pain thorn out
of heartache born out of being an abuse
kid who could go inside of his head and
create a world and imagination also that
a same abused kid watching his mother
it's nothing like a boy child I don't
know what it's like for a girl but a man
child watching his mother getting beaten
and there's nothing he can do my desire
and
heart to make her laugh and feel better
was so strong and you know if I could
make a joke or if I can imitate her or
my heart to make her laugh or some of
the women she'd play cards with on
Friday nights all of that was so
powerful and so important to me today
Perry is a parent himself and while he
is very much in the public eye he makes
a point of keeping his four-year-old son
Aman out of the spotlight you have
called him a healer for you for real
what do you mean by that
because I look at him and I'm looking at
myself at that age and I'm wondering how
anybody could be cruel and unkind to
this disel level of pure innocence and
beauty and if in love and love I do I
had to discipline him one day because he
was having a problem with the nanny and
he was just cutting up and he's just in
the bathroom he doesn't want to brush
his teeth and he goes so I open the door
and he just freezes and looks at me and
I asked her nanny lever and I sat down
with them got down I died and I'm
talking to him and as I'm talking to him
I'm realizing I didn't really need to
run out of the room because I'm about to
start crying I'm talking to him I'm
telling him how much I love my master's
mom and I love them and how
disrespectful this is and how
disappointed I am that he is behaving
this way he's much smarter than this
you're such a smart kid why are you
doing this you can't behave this way
because other kids do that this is not
what you do it's not what we do as
parents we teach you better than this so
I'm trying to finish and he's just
crying and shaking just and trying to
calm that's a pop I'm so sorry I'm
trying to calm down I've run out of the
room right
without him noticing it because it broke
me I've realized that nobody had ever
talked to me like a person as a child
nobody had ever talked to me like a
human being right so that's what I mean
when I say my my healer I'm never ever
eat I'm I talk to him every time I hug
him every time I love him and let him
know he's special there's something in
me that's being healed
Tyler what do you want your legacy to be
I would love for my son first of all
just to be an amazing person you talk so
lovingly about Amnon is it impolite to
say can you now have a little baby girl
it's very
[Laughter]
a girl can't ride other than his partner
Galil a really wonderful couple and this
little boy is one of the sweetest boys
that you that you'll ever meet he's
certainly being raised right but it
struck me about many things about what
Tyler Perry did this weekend everybody
who was there left feeling inspired
thinking what more can I do I need to do
something with my life to a tee we've
all been talking about it but he did
something very special for the cast who
started who made him he says who
contributed to he was today the stars
from the original Tyler Perry shows like
House of Pain the Browns haven't
have-nots they all got a star in the
they had their own one of the Oprah
Winfrey sound studios and then they had
a moment and they were crying was just a
very sweet thing when I was talking
about it yesterday my son called me and
said how come you didn't mention that
part that was one of the most touching
things well you can't get everything in
this is what Tyler said if you want
success work like you're broke yeah work
actually broke business is difficult and
building some things but when you put
what I love is the symbolism he's added
to it he's still doing big he told us
he's building a compound at the studios
his next big dream we're gonna put it
online to show you what he wants to do
it's massive